desliza carga asegura y sale hacia el
avión que lo llevará a destino en
contenedores así se transportarán las
vacunas contra el cob y 19 dentro pueden
llevar hasta 6 mil dosis una de las
dificultades conservar la vacuna de
facer a temperaturas controladas de
hasta menos 80 grados que técnicamente
menos 80 grados es posible hacerlo no es
lo más fácil pero es factible no es lo
más fácil porque es mantener menos 80
grados a lo largo de toda la cadena
desde que sale del laboratorio hasta la
clínica es un lapso bastante largo este
boeing 777 podría llevar hasta un millón
de vacunas se necesitarán unos 8000
jumbos para llevar la primera dosis a
todos los habitantes del planeta
transportar esta vacuna ha sido tildado
de desafío del siglo
casi a última hora sabremos
efectivamente donde se fabricarán las
vacunas y hacia dónde habrá que
despachar las eso también será un gran
desafío ya vivimos uno con el transporte
de las mascarillas durante la primavera
pasada ahora vamos a la siguiente etapa
con la noción de temperatura de urgencia
y estas incertidumbres acerca del
volumen y del destino
desde septiembre air france formó un
grupo de trabajo para estudiar las
hipótesis entre ellas reforzar la
seguridad de tan preciado bien el centro
de control será el encargado de seguir
el flujo de los aviones de carga
internamente tenemos procedimientos muy
estrictos en materia de seguridad y de
protección
es por eso que también tenemos este
grupo en la plataforma de rois y en la
que participa la gendarmería que
vigilará todo el flujo que pasará por
rossi
y un último obstáculo las vacunas
tardarían en llegar por los trámites
aduaneros y las cuarentenas impuestas a
las tripulaciones en ciertas zonas del
mundo